[Musique]
ben mon rôle c'est justement c'est ben
de gérer tout le service restauration
c'est-à-dire aussi bien la gestion des
menus la gestion des commandes la
gestion du personnel tout ce qui touche
la traçabilité alimentaire c'est-à-dire
qu'on appelle HCCP que tout le monde
connaît sur ce nom-là et aussi tout ce
qui touche le bon déroulement du service
ainsi que le personnel qui travaille
avec
[Musique]
moi missions sont simples c'est donc
accueillir orienté dirigé vers les
services concernés donc comment on
appelle ça souvent donc on est agent
d'accueil donc on est le front office
c'est la première personne de
l'administration de comme agent qu' va
trouver à l'entrée
[Musique]
nettoyer l'état Branger des chaises
essuer le tableau vider la poubelle et
remettre en
état l'enseignant arrive les élèves
arrivent les on est prêt à ça soit prête
à accueillir les élèves dans des bonnes
[Musique]
conditions comme Laurent Ry et Alain ils
sont une vingtaine d'agents du
département à assurer le bon fonction du
collège Bourbon leurs missions vont de
l'accueil des élèves à la restauration
en passant par l'entretien des bâtiments
et des espaces verts des agents au
service de la collectivité mais engagés
au bon encadrement de ces jeunes
[Musique]
élèves comme tous les jours après la
sonnerie du matin Rémi Mitra ferme le
portail du collège il est agent
d'accueil et c'est avec lui que se font
toutes les entrées et sorties de
l'établissement à certain heure le
portail sera fermé et une fois que le
portail est fermé si vous êtes pas
accompagn des parents vous pouvez entrer
ça faut pas l'oublier et le portail est
ouvert à partir de 7h le
matin je va vous passer le secrétariat
monsieur un
moment vous faites aussi l'accueille
téléphonique ben l'agent d'accueil on
fait tout accueil il y a l'accueil
téléphonique et l'accueil physique comme
je vous expliqué au début l'accueil
physique donc tout personnes étrangèrant
qui rentre et ben bien sûr
automatiquement c'est le le premier
travail à faire c'est l'accueil
téléphonique c'est pareil c'est dirigé
orienté donc les appels et donner les
renseignement nécessaires à 62 ans Rémy
gère l'accueil depuis 6 ans maintenant
il assure également la sécurité la
gestion du courrier la mise à
disposition des clés pour les
professeurs une pièce maîtresse dans
tout le rouage de l'administration
donc donc ici c'est votre bureau voilà
c'est le bureau bon il y a on on a un
ordinateur ça c'est pour gérer l'emploi
du temps il y a l'ordi le matin quand
j'arrive all regarde si on a des
renseignements quoi des des mails de
l'administration pour s'il y a des gens
qui sont donc convoqués invités à à
passer de tes ces années là comme j'ai
toujours dit c'est le contact humain qui
est le plus important aussi bien avec
que soit avec les quand il y a des
soucis des petites petites élèves 6e qui
arrivent en retard et que même s un
règlement qui n demande de de fermer le
portail mais quelque fois il faut aussi
réagir en tant que pi de famille et là
aller les voir et voir si on peut les
faire rentrer au moins sécuriser c'est
moi j'ai vu des petites filles pleurer
parce qu'elles étaient en retard donc ça
c'est c'est émouvant et donc ça veut
dire que ils aiment bien l'école et puis
bon puis ils ont peur aussi bon pour il
y a d'autres qui bon c'est pas grave s
rentre pas parce que pour quand c'est
fermé pour c'est mais il y a il faut
gérer tout ça il faut gérer la partie
humaine d'un
règlement alain fravette est adjoint
technique territorial il s'occupe de
l'entretien des locaux ainsi que des
espaces verts depuis 38 ans tous les
jours Alain prépare les salles de classe
avant l'arrivée des élèves alors le
matin j'arrive à 6h alors je prends mon
srieux avec tout ce qu' dessus pour le
nettoyage les produits pour la table
adaptés pour la table et puis on
commence on commence salle de
classe Alain gère différentes missions
pas toujours visiblebl mais
indispensable au bon fonctionnement de
l'établissement après toutes ces années
passé au collège Bourbon Alain se
prépare à partir à la retraite avec
beaucoup de fierté sur son engagement
déjà mon travail je l'aime mon
travail j'essaie de donner le le maximum
que je peux
et je me plais la pruve en est je je
suis toujours là aujourd'hui et puis
j'ai pu voir aussi toute
l'évolution matériel
surtout depuis cette dage qu'aujourd'hui
bon on n pas cessé d'améliorer les
conditions de travail
[Musique]
quoi et pendant que les collégiens
profitent d'une dernière pause matinale
en cuisine les agents
àair dans du service là premier service
c'est tout le personnel de
l'établissement qui mange qui passe
avant et après à partir de 11h30 on
accueille les élèves jusqu'à
13h30 Laurent mirenville est chef de
cuisine au collège Bourbon avec son
équipe composée de H agents il prépare
le menu de ce midi près de 1000 repas
seront servis en self avec une entrée un
plat et un
dessert donc on a fait un menu assez on
va dire euh pas je dirais pas simple je
dirais un menu que tout le monde aime
c'està dire un rantonné on est entr dans
frillon fromage fromage plus euh un
dessert un dessert c'est-à-dire
nectarine et kiwi ce midi donc c'est
rapide à servir pour nous le temps que
les élèves prennent leur marque aussi à
la restauration scolaire ou dans dans
les collèges et après bah le r cantonné
bah tout le monde adore ça donc
forcément c'est un PL qui plaît et qui
est rapide à servir en même temps à 36
ans Laurent occupe ce poste depuis 6 ans
maintenant formé à l'école hôtelière de
la Réunion il est particulièrement
sensible au goût et à l'équilibre de ses
repas les produits pays ont une saveur
toute particulière dans sa
cuisine r quantonné la le truc qu'on
peut mettre en avant ici c'est 100% pays
à part le riz tout est 100% pays
làdedans donc voilà c'est important de
souligner ça parce que bon dans les
collectivités faut pas oublier que bon
conseil général on met touour on fait
toujours en sorte de mettre les produits
locaux en avant parce que bon ben faut
pas oublier nos petits copains
agriculteurs les entreprises
agroalimentaire qui to aussi à la
Réunion donc forcément l'agriculur il
voit son carotte làdedans il do se dire
voilà ça serv à quelque chose
voilà ce que j'aime bien dans ce métier
là c'est ben c'est tous les jours c'est
un nouveau départ c'est jamais pareil
c'est jamais le même travail c'est que
chaque recette à son sa différence
chaque personne apporte sa pierre
apporte un petit coup apporte son
expérience surtout et le but làdans
c'est que bon ben tous les gens se
réveillent tous les Gour on un défi on
travaille toujours en flendu et c'est ce
que j'adore parce que le but làd c'est
que c'est de de créer un résultat avec
différentes personnes apporter un
résultat pour donner satisfaction à
l'élève et c'est ça tous les matins je
me réveille en me disant ah aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ça va être
bien ça va bien se passer B donc on fait
tout pour que tout se passe
bien le département de La Réunion gère
77 collèges qui accueille près de 56000
élèves les agents de la collectivités
qui travaillent ont donc un rôle
essentiel dans l'accueil et le bien-être
de ces jeunes en quête de
naissance